Lo que haremos en este video es trabajar con dos
rectángulos que tienen exactamente la misma área
y vamos a medir cada uno de ellos con una unidad
cuadrada distinta. La primera unidad cuadrada que
tenemos en la parte de arriba es 1 metro cuadrado,
eso significa que su altura es 1 metro y este
ancho por aquí también es 1 metro. Ahora, esta
segunda unidad cuadrada que tenemos por aquí es
completamente una invención, así que pongámosle un
nombre, vamos a llamarle 1 zetro cuadrado, así que
este de aquí es 1 zetro, mientras que su ancho
también será de 1 zetro. Así que este cuadrado
mide 1 zetro cuadrado, mientras que el cuadrado de
arriba claramente mide 1 metro cuadrado. Ahora,
midamos el rectángulo de arriba en términos
de metros cuadrados y midamos el rectángulo
de abajo en términos de zetros cuadrado. Primero
empecemos con el rectángulo superior. Tenemos:
1 metro cuadrado, 2 metros cuadrados, 3 metros
cuadrados, 4 metros cuadrados, 5 metros cuadrados
y 6 metros cuadrados; y luego tenemos otros
6 metros cuadrados aquí abajo, entonces: 7,
8, 9, 10, 11, 12. Por lo tanto, cuando
colocamos estos azulejos de 1 metro
cuadrado en el rectángulo original, parece
que tenemos un mosaico de 12 metros cuadrados,
así que podemos escribir su área como 12 metros
cuadrados. Ahora, ¿qué hay de este término de
zetros cuadrados? Hagamos el mismo ejercicio
por aquí: tenemos 1 zetro cuadrado, 2 zetros
cuadrados, y podemos decir, por último, 3 zetros
cuadrados, es decir, la misma área puede ser de
12 metros cuadrados y de 3 zetros cuadrados. Y
quiero que pienses por qué esto tiene sentido:
piensa en cuántos metros cuadrados comprenden o
equivalen a 1 zetro cuadrado. De hecho podemos
descubrirlo justo aquí: tenemos 1 metro cuadrado,
2 metros cuadrados, 3 metros cuadrados y,
por último, 4 metros cuadrados. Parece que
4 metros cuadrados hacen 1 zetro cuadrado.
Así que piénsalo: ¿tiene sentido que 3 zetros
cuadrados sean lo mismo que 12 metros cuadrados?